could I toss this question to Mike
McCarthy you want it if you want to talk
to me feel like just explaining that
possibility for a minute or two ago I'm
Mike hello so I work for the city's
Department technology and I'm for a
while I've definitely appreciated the
shows of the Castro every Christmas and
to your point I build a community Wi-Fi
networks along with at impose our router
flaws with Tim and we also have built
that public Wi-Fi as of a city
department but Tim and I have sort of
our little Tim and Mike network that
provides Tim and Mike's excellent
network there you go
buy the rights now that provides free
Wi-Fi Internet at about 70 80 sites
around the city and we use unique
strands a city fiber that all go back to
a building called 200 Paul Turner Paul
is a commercial data center at Paul and
third out the Bayview used to be an old
Sears warehouse and Macy's clearly Tim
knows more Macy's site that's pretty
much whatever you click on the Internet
on the network on your phone or device
your packets go through that building
most lightly so we have a what's called
a cross connect out to the public
Internet of the abreu strengthen an
archive in a Brewster and Ralph donate a
one gig pipe to the public Internet so
to your your point
there are we haven't really thought that
far out but there are possibilities to
build a sort of secondary network off
that as long as the sites that are
connected via fiber all have electricity
the light can travel through those
devices and get to 200 Paul assuming
Turner Paul's up and running but I think
if you have I think Rick sort of alluded
to this but if you really want to get
more deep details about the internet and
how it works
Tim clearly knows a whole lot tim has a
very interesting project called
F mix SF mix is a non-profit peering
fabric and peering is basically making
sure your packets of data don't leave
the building to go to Netflix but they
go through another cabinet that have a
connection between the sites so peering
is I think a really interesting you know
next step of this anyway I've got to
talk more about this at the break thanks
[Music]